let's go um let's go back to Chris from
Atlanta who says he has fixed his audio
Chris welcome
hey thanks Dave can you hear me this
time yes
wonderful wonderful well uh yeah I was
just sitting here you know watching
election results and everything and
um was kind of
thinking about the Stacey Abrams race
and I wanted to get your take on it as
far as you know maybe where you think
uh her campaign failed if you're that
familiar with it and and if you could
maybe compare and contrast say her
campaign to
similar one like Beto O'Rourke
um you know kind of similar matches
there going up against incumbent
Republicans and yeah listen where they
failed and where they did well I don't
know that Abrams failed per se I think
there were a bunch of different things
going on one is that Georgia really is a
red State particularly internally even
though you know Biden won the presidency
Georgia really is a red State when it
comes to their internal politics it's
difficult to knock off an incumbent
governor
Kemp to some degree resisted Trump's
urges to overturn the election in 20. so
not only did you have I mean listen
none of the Trump people were going to
vote for Stacey Abrams and then in
addition you have Republicans who may
not have been big on Trump who probably
saw Kemp as like hey you know what he's
one of the good Republicans Trump asked
him for 11 000 votes and he didn't do it
uh so so that helped him a little bit
and I I think it was mostly that I mean
I I think Stacy Abrams is a great
candidate now you could say well Stacey
Abrams is black was the racism was race
a factor she lost by a lot you know so
of course you you can't ever eliminate
that as a factor but I think it's more
sort of like the status quo of Georgia
Internal politics
right I mean race and gender aside I
mean that's a big a big hump to over
overcome in the first place but from
from my perspective you know in Georgia
and you know watching the media and
everything like that is is from my
perspective she didn't quite fight hard
enough and was a wasn't vocal and out
there in the news cycle enough you know
I feel like they she kind of
almost fell into the Trap of the GOP
where they said all right well we're
just we're going to bring Herschel and
let Herschel dominate our voters are
going to vote for us you know down
ballot are for the most part anyway I
mean that happened but I don't know how
much it was an overt strategy
of the GOP yeah you mean
right maybe not not now strategy like
all together for all their races but you
know I think they definitely
you know Stacy and her campaign
had opportunity to to be more visible
and they just weren't you know
visibility also depends on the media's
willingness to cover you you know and
you're right that the Walker Warnock got
a lot more oxygen and we did what we
could we would regularly cover the race
cover her debate cover the disaster of
Brian Kemp but part of that is also the
idea
but similar to Beto I mean you make your
own news
we have to get out there listen I think
she's great I think she's great and
sadly I do too didn't prevail
yeah same all right my friend Chris from
Atlanta great to hear from you great to
hear from everybody who I was able to
speak to today we're going to take a
quick break and I promise you we are
going to take calls again